things are not looking good for luc
besson sci-fi epic valerian and a city
of a thousand planets the expensive film
was obliterated at the domestic box
office in its opening weekend falling in
fifth place with only 17 million dollars
against the reported a hundred and
eighty million dollar production budget
considering the weight person's name
carries with sci-fi fans many may be
surprised to hear that his most recent
outing had that much trouble finding an
audience
however there were actually quite a few
warning signs of valerian would fail
here are the real reasons why valerian
was an intergalactic disappointment at
the box office
little-known source material valerian is
based on the French comic strip which
ran from 1967 to 2010 the son had been
reading the comics since he was a child
and dreamed of adapting it into a film
for years but he had to wait until he
had the right technology and experience
to pull off the comics unique vision
despite his wide readership overseas
though the comic never quite found an
audience in the United States so when
the title for the sounds passion project
popped up on potential audiences feeds a
lot of people weren't as familiar with
the comic characters as some of those
other superhero stories that tend to
tear up the box-office the familiarity
factor that such a draw for similar
adventure movies was gone right from the
start
story confusion compounding the
confusion was the fact that valerian
seemed to offer audiences vague
marketing materials that did little to
explain what Alerian was actually about
the previews focused heavily on the film
style over its content and focused on
off-putting aspects of the story
none of the trailers took the time to go
through the reality of the threats
against alpha or to discuss why valerian
and Laura lein were chosen to stop it
which made the previews for your hollow
and unimpressionable we need to kill
with you to be the Guardian well the
marketing might have drawn in a few
viewers who want to see persons' visual
spectacle unfold focusing entirely on
the style over substance and the
marketing wasn't necessarily a smart
choice
since a lot of would-be audience members
aren't familiar with the comic series
that's a lack of understanding may have
just been a turn-off at the ticket booth
ho-hum reviews some well-established
sci-fi worlds have been able to pull in
both dedicated and casual fans alike
while others have struggled to find the
mass-market appeal necessary to make up
their huge budgets as with any movie
with an unusual premise good reviews can
be a huge boost to creating audience
interest when there's not already
established fun baits in place with
valerian though the critical love line
wasn't quite there some reviews panda
leads for not having chemistry and
called the story empty with the
impressive visuals being singled out as
a lone point of positivity for the film
those middling reviews were hardly
enough to bring in sci-fi skeptics had
maybe been on the fence about seeing the
movie up-and-coming actors although Dane
DeHaan and cara de valine are both
well-known amidst industry circles
neither have established themselves as
bankable blockbuster stars just yet to
harness best known for his indie film
appearances more Delevingne only
recently made the switch for muddling
into the movie star business even those
popcorn flick sea have appeared in the
amazing spider-man 2 and Suicide Squad
respectively were largely
disappointments and did nothing to prove
their profitability or earn them
household name recognition stiff
competition the opening weekend for
valerian was packed with alternative
options for the theater going crowd
including Christopher Nolan's widely
praised war epic Dunkirk the film
offered the visual dynamism valerian
promised and it had gripping true
stories subject matter at the center
meanwhile the r-rated ensemble comedy
girls trip offered viewers a chance to
let loose and enjoy some adult humor
which may have been a draw in for those
who are experiencing a bit of superhero
summer fatigue the film also came out
just two weeks
the Marvel's juggernaut spider-man
homecoming and just one week after the
trilogy ender war for the Planet of the
Apes more both films saw their box
office performances pushed beyond
initial expectations due to strong
reviews it was easy to see that they'd
have legs long past their release dates
the combined array of those four other
options might have given theater goers
some pause about choosing to see
valerian to creative salvation a number
of different figures have been thrown
around for Valerians budget but they all
point to one thing it was high the film
which has been reported as the most
expensive French production of all time
likely cost somewhere around 200 million
dollars including markets air well time
flies when you're having fun
that means it'll require a pretty
stellar comeback in order to make a
profit however there is still some hope
for valerian like many domestic flops in
the summer of 2017
the international box office could be a
savior the movie is expected to do big
business in France where viewers are
familiar with the comics and will
continue to be rolled out in
international territories throughout the
summer the best hope for the film
however comes from vasanas creative
method of financing it tax credits are
one of the film's first help us with
estimates saying that they bump the
film's cost down by fifty million
dollars the movie is also said to be
covering significant parts of its budget
through equity financing and foreign
pre-sales still the slow staff of
valerian is not a good sign for the film
in the long run and is an even worse
sign for the sounds already planned the
follow-up films the movie will have to
do significant business overseas in
order to be considered a success and it
seems unlikely that it will be able to
break its perception as a box-office
flop thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love ting